[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you want to give odds here paulie
because i'd maintain all long aaron
rodgers is in green bay to start this
season
at this point barring injury right or
he's a scheduled day one starter for the
packers
barring massive injury yes i would bet a
thousand to anyone's 500.
a thousand to 500 yeah anybody all right
well let me see if floria wants a piece
of that he's got money mike florio pro
football talk live joining us now
uh you want to jump in on this mike no
no i don't one of the reasons i have
money is i don't waste
gambling look i i
i go back and forth on this too it's a
beautiful mystery
it's what aaron rodgers wants us to
think he wants us to not know
i think the packers specifically
the ceo mark murphy doesn't want him to
show up
i think he's daring him to not show up i
think that's the only way to make sense
of that gratuitous remark he made last
week calling him a
complicated fella i think murphy would
rather move on with jordan love
save 35 million dollars in salary
and they would get bonus money back from
aaron rodgers
they don't have to worry about him
playing for the broncos or anyone else
and making them look stupid
now they can trade him after the season
but i think at this point murphy you
attach him to a lie detector test he'd
have to say
yeah i'd rather the guy not show up this
year and maybe maybe that vibe
makes aaron rodgers more determined to
show up
but you want to trade him don't you to
get something for him so you wouldn't
you wouldn't do anything now you would
wait until after the season
yeah i think at this point you get more
after the season you get more teams to
the table you'll be like peyton manning
in 2012 you'd have 10 teams
yeah i think you'd easily have 10 teams
after the season right now
you got the broncos maybe the raiders
maybe the raiders raiders saying all the
right things about derek carr but if
aaron rodgers becomes available and
you're looking at him going to the
broncos
how do you at least not make a phone
call if
for no reason other than to drive up the
price the broncos have to pay but
but after the season when we have
another
i was going to say 256 it's now 272
games
teams will look at their quarterbacks
and say got to get rid of that guy oh
aaron rodgers is available let's go get
in line and try to get him
yeah i'm just trying to understand the
timing of all of this mike that
if you're rogers give me roger's side of
this that
what what is the end game for him this
year
well i find it fascinating dan guys like
james jones who played with rogers
still talked to rogers and more
importantly rogers still talks to them
after they do media and say what rogers
has said i think rogers is doing a
little puppet mastery
through guys like james jones he says
it's fixable it's fixable well
okay then then fix it tell us what it's
going to take to fix it
what does it take i i don't know and i
as i told you on friday
i think this is a high stakes pr battle
where each side is trying to make the
other side look like the bad guy
and i just think right now aaron rodgers
wants to create
chaos what was the line from one of the
batman movies some men just like to see
the world burn
i think that rogers is just trying to
make the front office of the packers
burn
it's one thing that he says he loves
everything about green bay he loves the
tradition he loves the fans he loves the
coaching staff he loves his teammates
so what if you don't like somebody in
management and if
and if it is fixable then what is it
that needs to be fixed is what i want to
know because you can't undraft jordan
love
that's not fixable unless you say we're
going to trade him and they don't want
to do
that here's your poll question for today
yes or no is there someone in management
at your workplace that you hate
overwhelmingly yes and you still show up
every day that sucks
so and it's not like he has to deal with
mark murphy in the locker room
and i would advise mark murphy and brian
gooda koontz to avoid the locker room in
the practice field this year unless
they're going to wear cups
but uh i yeah just you're there with
your teammates you're there with your
head coach you're there for the fans
i just the whole thing is is pr driven
and
who knows what aaron rodgers wants and
that's what he wants
he wants us talking about him and he
wants to reserve the right to say why
are you talking about it yeah but i
don't know what the end game
is mike does he is he willing to sit out
and not play football this year
um does he want to be traded like at
some point you have to get to
now let's sit down and discuss what's
going to happen here is he just going to
show up and play football this year and
act as if none of this happened i i
thought for a long time
that that's what he would do dan that he
would show up and basically say what's
what's the big deal is there
you know a booger that i'm unaware of
why is everyone looking at me
and and act like it's a media creation
because it always is our fault
obviously yeah they create the template
that we react to and it's our fault for
reacting to it
but i just really truly don't know and i
change my
mind all the time and i think i am
am a victim of what he's trying to
create it would be very easy for him to
say what he wants
how he wants it he doesn't have to
packers fans get upset with me or more
accurately aaron rodgers fans get upset
with me
when i say he should tell people what he
wants no he doesn't have to
but when you don't you you create these
situations where we end up obsessing
over what the guy wants because
for whatever reason he won't tell us
what he wants is mike florio
uh pro football talk live co-host with
chris sims
you've got what less than two weeks for
the veterans to show up
two weeks today what's going to happen
with desean watson
is he eligible to show up for training
camp
this is a a great question that has
taken a back seat to the aaron rodgers
drama and nick casario the gm
of the texans was on radio in houston
yesterday
and he said what the talking points have
been for weeks now they're not saying
anything about watson etc but at the end
of the answer he said
as we get close to training camp we'll
make the best
decision that we can in the interest of
the houston texans i
dan i i think that
the texans have been hoping and i know
that the texans have been hoping
that the 22 lawsuits pending against
deshaun watson would be settled because
if they're settled
you're able to trade watson and you're
able to get a lot for him in trade that
that's the thing that teams
are are waiting to have go away
if they can properly resolve the cases
and i've been an advocate of desean
watson
facing the music having his reckoning
making these 22 individuals feel like
they've gotten justice
had their quasi day in court write the
check and move on with your life
and then he can be traded there's a
possibility
that the texans are going to have to
make a decision
without the cases being settled what do
you do with desean watson
as training camp arrives do you trade
him for whatever you can get
which is a lot less if the 22 cases are
pending or do you let him
show up because i think he will show up
because he gets put on paid leave
which people think will happen texas
have to pay 10 million dollars to not
play for them
this year so i think for the texans they
have to ask if the cases aren't settled
do we just take whatever we can get
bargain basement deal to trade watson
or do we run the risk of paying them 10
minutes and the other side of it too
and sims and i were talking about this
earlier today
at some point the league i think owes it
to watson the texans and any team that
would want to trade
for watson to give people an inkling of
what they're thinking are you putting
them on paid leave
you know they had a lot of uncertainty
with antonio brown two years ago
they wouldn't tell teams what they were
going to do and then no one would touch
him
with this he's under contract he's
getting 10 million this year from
somebody
i think they should let the relevant
people know what they're going to do
so people can make their their best
decisions about what they're going to do
moving forward
the most interesting training camps will
be where
well obviously green bay i mean that's
again whether rogers is there or not
there
it's either gonna be rogers and
you know making his passive aggressive
comments and then getting mad when
people point out that he's made passive
aggressive comments which i always like
seattle is going to be compelling
because
yeah hey did you hear russell wilson
never asked for a trade no he didn't
have to he went on your show and he made
it clear he wants out and then his agent
comes out and says well my client
doesn't want to be traded but in the
event that you are traded these are the
four teams he played for
of course he was disgruntled and unhappy
he was
miserable at the super bowl watching
patrick mahomes and tom brady
how's that gonna go are they able to set
all that aside and is he on board with
the shane waldron offense and
you know the the jaguars training camp
just for sheer entertainment purposes
with tim tebow and
the college approach that urban meyer is
bringing to town is that going to work
so
you know there's always that short list
of of must-see
training camps that obviously never end
up being the subject of hard knocks but
i wish they would
okay let me you touched on tim tebow i
thought he was going to be a big
distraction
we we haven't had that distraction with
tim tebow
uh when is that going to happen well
they've kept him
from talking to reporters and i'm not up
on the rules of when
access is mandatory in the offseason
once you get into the regular season
everyone's got to be available at least
once during the week and after each game
but the weirdest things happen dan
there's been at least two straight urban
meyer press conferences
and the folks covering the jaguars
haven't asked about t-bone
just haven't asked about it and i get
the impression locally
they've gotten used to it and that's
helped
this kind of not be a factor he's just
kind of going about his business
and i don't know or are they getting the
vibe that meyer doesn't want to be asked
about him i don't know but he's there
they're selling jerseys and he's quietly
learning the tight end position
i still think he's going to be on the
team this year they're going to find a
way to get him on the team on the field
catching one yard touchdown passes
throwing one yard touchdown passes or
having one yard rushing touchdowns it'll
be awesome
it'll it'll be awesome it's that's
another cottage industry
do you realize the cottage industries we
have in our world
like aaron rodgers that's a cottage
industry
that it the story about those covering
the stories
lebron is a cottage industry tom brady
is a cottage industry there's certain
guys that
you have i mean the mothership has moved
people around from
city to city to cover lebron james
hey we want you to relocate to los
angeles to cover lebron
it's pretty it's pretty crazy dan people
ask me why do i keep writing and talking
about aaron rodgers easy response i am a
businessman
i have access real time to my traffic
i see which stories people read i give
the people what they want isn't it funny
in this business
you've got the people who give the fans
and the readers what they want
and then you've got the people who give
them what they think they
should want and those are the ones that
don't stay in business
it's that simple
uh i'll check back in with you soon mike
thank you
thank you bud that's uh mike florio pro
football talk live
co-host